there was darkness in the deep and water
without form and there was a subtle
breath intelligent which permeated the
things in chaos with divine power then
when all was yet undistinguished and
unwrought there was shed forth Holy
Light and the elements came into being
all things were divided one from another
and the lighter things were parted off
on high the fire being suspended aloft
so that it rose unto the air and the
heavier things sank down and sand was
deposited beneath the watery substance
and the dry land was separated out from
the watery substance and became solid
and the fiery substance was articulated
with the gods therein and heaven
appeared with its seven spheres and the
gods visible in starry forms with all
their constellations and heaven revolved
and began to run it's circling course
riding upon the divine air and each God
by his several power set forth that
which he was bidden to put forth and
there came forth forefoot and beasts and
creeping things and fishes and winged
birds and grass and every flowering herb
all having seed in them according to
their diverse natures for they generated
within themselves the seed by which
their races should be renewed
you must understand them that God is
pre-existent and ever existence ever
existent and that he alone made all
things and created by his will the
things that are and when the creator had
made the ordered universe he willed to
set in order the earth also he will to
set in order the earth also and so he
sent down man a mortal creature made in
the image of an immortal being to be an
embellishment of the divine body for it
is man's function here it comes the
purpose of man for according to book for
for it is man's function to contemplate
the works of God and for this purpose he
was made that he might view the universe
with wondering law and come to know its
maker man has this advantage over all
other living beings that he possesses
mind and speech now speech my son God
imparted to all men but mine he did not
impart
to all not that he grudged it to end for
the grudging temper does not start from
heaven above but comes from being here
below in the souls of those men who are
devoid of money this introduces the
concept of the of an elect or a
perfecting a hierarchy of human of human
accomplishment and understanding and
this is also basic to Gnosticism it's
not for everyone
they're saying it's for the pure of
heart and then what pure of heart means
depends on the school you're looking at
you know for some it was mathematical
accomplishment for others it was contact
with the logos for others it was an
ability to resist the temptations of the
senses but there was always this sense
of the higher and lower possibility
within the human experience everybody
with me so far
okay this is book 12 now this whole
cosmos which is a great God and an image
of him who is greater and is united with
him and maintains its order in
accordance with that will is one mass of
life and there is not anything in the
cosmos nor has been through all time
from the first foundation of the
universe neither in the whole nor among
the several things contained in it that
is not alive there is not and has never
been and never will be
in the cosmos anything that it is dead
for it was the Father's will that the
cosmos as long as it exists should be a
living being and therefore it must needs
be a god
also how then my son could there be dead
things in that which is a god and that
which is an image of the father in that
which is one mass of life deafness is
corruption and corruption is destruction
how then can any part of that which is
incorruptible be corrupted or any part
of that which is a god be destroyed
you